[Applaudissements]
mathieu grosbost vous avez quelque chose
à ajouter coûté sûr que son programme
voilà soit à l'image de ces fiches râler
tout est dit c'est nul c'est nul je peux
ajouter quelque chose quand même parce
que je sais qu'en ce moment il se passe
beaucoup de choses il à faire fillon et
puis parfois les dossiers qui traînent
me concernant me concernant je dois la
vérité aux français et vous le savez que
j'ai souvent dit je veux un corps sain
dans un esprit sain voilà ou plutôt l
inverse un esprit sain dans un corps
sain c'est vous dire si si verdez doit
être torturés et me concernant je suis
prêt à vous et des choses et oui je vais
l'avouer j'ai pas fait de sextape tout
ça mais je le reconnais devant vous
devant les français voilà c'est vrai je
mets à nu
oui c'est vrai que j'ai fait des
couleurs ou sur 12 mais tout ça c'est
terminé
d'accord gilles verdez matthieu
delormeau vous pensez à vous je pense
aux autres vous vous admirez dans le
miroir moi je regarde à travers le
miroir pour comprendre le monde
je vais gouverner avec l'âme généreuse
vous parlez de beauté de physique la
beauté c'est un critère subjectif la
générosité elle est universelle et
excusez moi c'est en train de nous
saouler le rabbin il est chiant on est
bien d'accord et c'est vrai avec des
chiens en détresse iran vous est chiant
il est tombé sur un gars bien d'accord
les chéris un mot de la fin chacun le
meneur américain et bien démarré par
gilles verdez ce qui est chiant voter
pour moi c'est voter pour vous ces
chirurgies en vous le savez je vous
défendrait je serai à vos côtés ou à la
finition
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
même ses supporters son chien je sais
que pour vous le peuple est chiant
mathieu mois président je présenterai
n'en pense que mathieu tous les jours de
la semaine et même le week-end
non mais ça c'est pas possible moi
président je serai président je n'ai pas
président oui moi président j'offrirai
les cadeaux à tous les téléspectateurs
comme vous stylo porte-clés pin's
parlant bintou saas à partir à moi
président je réaliserai le gel le rêve
de gilles verdez en faisant participer à
koh lanta et il y restera
merci d'ailleurs denis brogniart mois
président je promets de faire un duo
avec gras dur certes écrire au président
je ne tournerait le dos à personne bah
vous avez bien raison est-ce que tu
allais dire place à deborah qui avoue
vous serez mon exception enfin moi par
exemple c'est bon vous emmerdez
accepterait enfin sur facebook
les demandes d'amis très nombreuses
johnny hallyday black'n kenji booba
texte tous ceux à qui jusqu'à maintenant
je n'avais pas dit non je vous
accepterait comme ami votez pour moi
vive la france
attention restez les chéris vous avez
encore une minute exactement pour voter
sur twitter et on aura le résultat dans
un instant je donnais qui vous a le plus
convaincu
alors non mais c'est la fin de matthieu
delormeau comme je ne veux absolument
pas de gilles verdez dans koh lanta a
enfin bien je vais voter pour gilles
verdez bien ici et qu'ils ne viennent
pas sur koh lanta et puis mathieu le
petits gilets en cachemire ça va pas du
tout la bernina président moderne
non non ça excite énormément sa couette
et café chic autre part entre les mains
alors moi je pense que la france a
besoin de jeunesse et pour ça je vais je
suis pas sûr qu'il soit devrait voir
réellement très jeune je vais voter pour
matthieu delormeau par travaux tout ça
merci mon caddie dans jeune et dynamique
gras dur pour moi tiens tiens
caroline la fougue de la jeunesse le
physique mathieu delormeau guillon à la
jeunesse la fraîcheur le pub le plus
gris mathieu voci gilles verdez il est
droit il est soit un plébiscite
pour ce jeune et de vieux je vote que
gilles verdez la beauté du coeur et
l'altruisme agile et laura 20e avait
menacé de révéler des dossiers si je ne
voterai pas pour lui je suis droite je
vote pour gilles verdez au aucun vrai
chevalier les pages à sa droite je me la
fais je donnerai des dossiers dans les
deux cas c'est un drame donc moi j'aime
beaucoup matthieu delormeau mais gilles
verdez est devenu un vrai beau gosse
donc les gilles verdez alors je vais
vous dire il reste dix secondes pour
voter il ya eu plus de 30 mille votes à
la maison durk sait varier le prix le
plus de 30000 vote c'était gilles verdez
a toujours été en tête il était à 81
puis 70 points puis 60 40
il ya un instant c'était 58 42 est-ce
que matthieu delormeau à renverser la
vapeur
est-ce que matthieu delormeau va être le
président le tps que matthieu delormeau
les deux ans
il nous reste dix secondes de vote
gilles verdez au match de lambeaux sa
chute lundi
votre vie va changer la date d'arrêté on
dire et redire et le décompte de nikos
au jour de l'an annabella panja pas des
cons ce métier on n'a pas les bars et
gilles verdez et mathieu sachez que
votre vie va changer lundi ce soit l'un
ou l'autre et si vous perdez vous devrez
vous rallier à votre président c'est
clair